on comprend bien pourquoi part d'un
problème avec edwy plenel comme vous le
savez maintenant dans cette émission un
des moments dans ce quoi et je sais que
vous aimez danser en fait oui mais mais
en privé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant et de vie vous avez été élevé
aux antilles absolument vous avez passé
10 ans de notre vie aux antilles son
père travaille là bas il ya même une
école alain plenel depuis quelques
semaines des da voilà pour les routes
n'ont
[Applaudissements]
donc pas rester en reste pour les
antilles sinon ça m'avait vexé moi je
les connais les antillais bien vu
attention
[Musique]
ouais
bien très bien qu way
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
or là bravo réduit les corrections de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus